Hallo, Sie!
Guten Tag!
Ich bin Klimas Unheuer Ersten und werde jetzt das mit Ihnen Aufnahmegesprech durchführen.
Bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid, wenn etwas unklar ist.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Manfred Simon.
Manfred Simon.
Können Sie bitte Vorname und Nachname langsam bestebieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist M-A-N-F-R-E-D.
Das ist ein männlicher Vorname.
Und der Familienname ist Simon, S-I-M-O-N.
Alles klar, danke.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin schon 76.
6 und 7, Sie.
Wie alt sind Sie geboren?
Am 25. April, 49.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78, war ich jedenfalls einmal, vielleicht bin ich schon ein bisschen kleiner.
Und ich wiege 89 kg noch.
Alles klar.
Welche Beschwarten haben Sie im Moment?
Ich fühle mich seit ein paar Monaten total schlapp und müde.
Ich habe auch richtig heftigen Husten immer wieder.
Manchmal tut mir das auch weh beim Husten in der Lunge.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich beim Treppensteigen,
dass ich da richtig eine Pause machen muss,
weil ich nicht mehr gut Luft bekomme.
Und dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass mein Herz ganz doll klopft.
Und diesen Husten habe ich schon ewig.
Ich habe schon ganz viel Hustensaft und Hustentropfen genommen
und Tee getrunken und so.
Der ist einfach immer bei mir, dieser Husten.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, in letzter Zeit,
dass ich manchmal so blutigen Schleim habe.
Und das hat mir dann doch nicht so gut gefallen.
Hat es geholfen, Tee?
Ja, der so ein bisschen Linde rumbringt es immer.
Aber letztendlich wird der Husten überhaupt nicht besser, würde ich sagen.
Gippes, bestimmte Auslöser für die Beschwade?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen.
Ich kann eigentlich nur sagen, dass es so mit so einem Grippe-Husten
irgendwo angefangen hat.
Und dann hat es eigentlich überhaupt nicht aufgehört.
Und jetzt ist das in den letzten Monaten, würde ich sagen,
immer schlimmer geworden.
Gippes, etwas dieser Beschwaden, Schlemmelt.
Zum Beispiel kalte Luft oder in den Naht?
Ja, also nachts kann ich nicht besonders gut schlafen.
Ja, da muss ich manchmal auf der Bettkante sitzen
und um zu Husten oder so.
Und kalte Luft kann ich eigentlich auch nicht so gut haben.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Herzprobleme?
Herzprobleme?
Herz.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist, eigentlich bisher nicht,
aber jetzt habe ich das so gemerkt, wenn ich die Treppe hoch gehe,
dass ich dann, also nicht nur, dass ich dann keine Luft bekomme,
sondern dass ich dann auch das Gefühl habe,
dass mir das Herz so bis zum Herz klopft, ja.
Herzklopfen.
Haben Sie Schluck bei Schwalten oder Schmerzen beim Schlucken?
Nein, also beim Schlucken selber habe ich eigentlich keine Schmerzen.
Also manchmal ist halt der Halt so ein bisschen,
vom ewigen Husten ist der so ein bisschen gereizt,
aber dann versuche ich mit Husten, Bonbons oder so,
das ein bisschen zu lindern.
Aber so richtige Halsschmerzen, die habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe das jetzt nicht gemessen, also ich wüsste nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrochen?
Nein, also richtig.
Übelkeit habe ich eigentlich nicht,
aber was mir aufgefallen ist in letzter Zeit,
dass mir eigentlich das Essen überhaupt nicht schmeckt.
Ich mag überhaupt nichts essen.
Und ja, dann überlege ich so, ja, was könnte ich mir denn mal machen?
Und ja, dann fällt mir gar nichts ein, was ich gerne essen würde.
Haben Sie weitere Beschwäde?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Ja, also zusammen, ja, weil ich jetzt eigentlich nicht gut gegessen habe in letzter Zeit,
habe ich auch ein bisschen an Gewicht verloren.
Ich habe das gemerkt, meine Hosen sind mir alle viel zu weit.
Ich muss überall den Gürtel enger schnallen.
Und auch meine Hemden sind hier oben am Hals ganz weit geworden, ja.
Also ich habe schon ein bisschen abgenommen.
Tut mir leid zu hören.
Wie viel Kilo habe ich verloren?
Also jetzt wiege ich ja noch 89 Kilo, aber ich war eigentlich mal ganz stocklich.
Ich habe mal 95 gewogen.
Und das ist gar nicht so lange her.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihren allgemeinen Gesundheitsstellen.
Haben Sie Schutelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Die eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Schutulgang?
Ja, also in meinem Alter, ich habe schon seit 10 Jahren, habe ich schon ein bisschen Prostatorprobleme.
Und also nachts muss ich schon, ja, 2-3 Mal muss ich schon auf die Toilette gehen.
Und dann nehme ich aber auch Tabletten dagegen.
Aber ich komme jetzt nicht drauf, wie die heißen.
Das könnte ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Aber also jedenfalls habe ich die Tabletten gegen diese Prostatorgeschichten.
Okay.
Was ist das Problem mit der Prostatorprobleme?
Ich habe die Tabletten für die Prostatorgeschichte vergrößert.
Ja, ja, die ist vergrößert und das wird immer wieder untersucht.
Und wir werden auch so diese Rohrwerte bestimmt.
Aber also bisher ist das alles so unauffällig.
Ja, und ich will auch tatsächlich nichts mehr an mir rumschnibbeln lassen.
Ich will keine Operation.
Mit meinem Alter, da will ich meine Ruhe haben.
Super.
Was ist das Problem mit der Blutdruck?
Ja, Blutdruck ist natürlich klar.
Ich war ja auch ganz schön übergewichtig.
Und ja, der Blutdruck ist schon seit 10 Jahren hoch.
Das weiß ich.
Und naja, was ich noch habe,
da habe ich schon mal eine Operation gehabt.
Und jetzt ist da wieder Bandscheibenproblem.
Und da habe ich hin und wieder mal Schmerzen.
Aber auch da, ich will es nicht operieren lassen.
Ja, nicht mehr, neid.
Haben Sie noch eine der Vorarl-Krankungen?
Ja, das linke Auge macht mir ein bisschen ärger.
Da kann ich nicht mehr auf die Schmerzen gehen.
Da habe ich grauen Stahl.
Sie sagen, ich habe das Bandscheibenvorfall und die Operation durchführen.
Und nochmal wurden Sie schon mal operiert.
Na ja, das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Ich habe auch eine Operation gemacht.
Und jetzt gibt es aber wieder neue Probleme.
Und das will ich nicht mehr operieren lassen.
Waren Sie schon mal in die Station im Krankenhaus?
Ja, ja, als Kind.
Da habe ich den Blinder rausbekommen.
Ja, Blinder.
Ich höre nicht.
Und jetzt ist es wieder ein Problem.
Ich habe auch eine Operation gemacht.
Ich höre nicht.
Und bei dieser Bandscheibenoperation war ich natürlich auch im Krankenhaus.
Das ist aber auch schon zehn Jahre her jetzt.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nein, nein, ich komme gar nicht mehr so richtig viel weg.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ach Sie meinen wegen Covid, ja.
Also da habe ich mich impfen lassen.
Und jetzt für diese Wintersaison habe ich schon meinen Termin.
Der ist in Kürze, ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Außer gegen Prostate?
Ja, also ich nehme etwas gegen den hohen Blutdruck.
Und dann habe ich Augen tropfen für das linke Auge.
Wie sind Sie die Medikamente Namen und Dosierung?
Also ich glaube, das ist gegen den Blutdruck, das ist Konkur.
Und da steht Konkur 5 drauf und da muss ich immer nur morgens eine Tablette nehmen.
Nur am morgens?
Okay. Augen tropfen viel viel am Tag?
Also da muss ich einmal morgens und einmal abends, aber wie die heißen weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin bei mir zu Hause im Badezimmer, ja.
Kein Problem. Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf oder finanzische Heimateln?
Ne sonst muss ich eigentlich nichts einnehmen.
Okay. Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Verzwechlichkeit?
Ja, was ich tatsächlich nicht nehmen darf, als Schmerzmittel ist Novalgin.
Da reagiere ich allergisch drauf und ich habe auch eine Allergie auf Jod.
Das hat man irgendwann mal festgestellt.
Ja, okay.
Wie äußert die Jod-Allergie und Novalgin-Allergie?
Ja, das ist jeweils so, dass ich so eine Gesichtsrötung bekomme.
Und auch bei dem Novalgin, weil das auch so, dass ich so Ausschlag an den Armen bekommen habe.
Und ja, das habe ich aber seit hier gar nicht mehr genau.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie Herr Simon?
Schon lange Zeit nicht mehr, aber ich habe tatsächlich ja, ich habe schon, also sagen wir es, ich rauche keine Zigaretten mehr.
Jetzt rauche ich hin und wieder mal eine Pfeife, ja.
Aber ja, ich habe lange Zeit wirklich heftig geraucht, ja.
Wie viele rauchen Sie am Tag?
Also jetzt rauche ich mal eine Pfeife am Abend oder auch mal zwei, aber früher habe ich, also schon, also mehr als ein Päckchen,
anderthalb Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ein Päckchen?
Damals konnte man bei der Arbeit noch rauchen, wissen Sie, ich war, ich war Busfahrer.
Und ja, da hat man früher noch richtig viel geraucht.
Okay.
Wie viele Jahre Sie Geräte und Pfeife gerauchen?
Erinneren Sie?
Also mit der Pfeife, das habe ich so vor zehn Jahren angefangen, als es mit dem Blutdruck war und diese ganzen Geschichten,
da habe ich, da habe ich dann, da haben wir die Ärzte auch gesagt, ja, Sie rauchen zu viel, versuchen Sie mal.
Da habe ich das mit den Zigaretten sein gelassen, aber also ja, 40 Jahre lang habe ich bestimmt diese großen Mengen geraucht, ja.
Ja, Sie.
Es fehlt noch besser, Sie, ganze Zigarette mit dem Rachen aufgehört.
Wenn Sie möchten, ich, ich, eine Programme in Krankenhaus bieten?
Also Sie meinen, Sie wollen mir ein Programm anbieten, wissen Sie, zurzeit schmecken wir das sowieso nicht.
Also mit diesem blöden Husken, da schmecken mir, die schmecken mir auf die Pfeife eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig gut, ja.
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das gut bald aufheben, ja.
Okay, kein Problem.
Trinken Sie?
Natürlich trinke ich, ja.
Mhm.
Was trinken Sie?
Morgens trinke ich mein Kaffee und nachmittags trinke ich auch nochmal Kaffee und, ja.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends der Flasche Bier ja, zum Abendbrot oder zum Feierabend, ja.
Mhm.
Für viele Jahre trinken Sie?
Ja, also seit ich erwachsen bin, ja.
Also bin ja nun alt geworden, ne.
Also bestimmt, ja, seit ich 18 bin oder 20 bin, ja.
Ja, seit dem Lebensjahr zum Beispiel.
Okay.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, nehmen Sie die Ruger.
Oh nein, das konnte ich mir natürlich nie erlauben bei meinem Beruf.
Nein, da habe ich auch keine Interesse dran.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Gib es in bestimmte Ehre, Familie, für Erkrankungen?
Ja, also.
Nicht Erkrankung?
Ja, mein Vater, der hatte einen Herzinfarkt tatsächlich.
Und er ist nicht so alt geworden und meine Mutter, die ist noch früher gestorben,
die hatte Brustkrebs, ja.
Leben, lebt ihr Vater noch?
Nein, nein, der ist mit 74, ist er gestorben, also der ist schon lange tot.
Mhm, ich sollte gehen.
Mein Vater?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war ein Tierkind.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin ein Fanzitwitz schon längere Zeit, ja.
Tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei erwachsene Töchter, die sind natürlich auch schon fast im Rentenalter, ja.
Mhm.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, so viel ich weiß, also das eine oder andere Zipperlein haben die natürlich auch mal,
aber also Grundlegend sind die, glaube ich, gesund, ja.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich manchmal stress?
Ich stress, in meinem Alter, nein, nein, nein, ich lasse mich nicht mehr stressen, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Haustiere?
Haustiere habe ich nicht, nein.
Sie sagen, ich bin Busfahrer.
Gewesen, ich bin Rentner natürlich jetzt, ne?
Ja, ich frage jetzt, okay, super.
Ja, schon lange.
Das waren alle meine Fragen, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, Herr Simon?
Also ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt, also was ich natürlich wissen möchte von Ihnen,
ja, was man gegen den Hausten jetzt machen kann, dass es mal endlich besser wird
und ob es vielleicht eine gute Medizin gibt dagegen oder so, irgendwas, was wirklich hilft.
Ja, was man dagegen tun kann, das wüsste ich schon gerne.
Machen Sie Sie nicht, machen Sie Sie keine Sorge.
Sie sind gute Hände und so als werde ich körperliche Untersuchungen und Laborprämite prüfen
und danach werde ich weitere Schritte informieren.
Sie werden mich über weiteres Schritte informieren.
Okay, ja.
Und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, was machen Sie da?
Ich palpiere Lampfknoten und Ihren Haas
und ich höre Lungen ab.
Ah ja, das kenne ich ja, von meinem Hausarzt auch.
Ja, okay, gut.
Okay, gut.
Das war alles?
Ja, möchte jemand noch etwas wissen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben sehr vollständig gefragt, ich wüsste kaum, was noch über sein könnte.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie fertig sind zum Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, ja?
Ich höre nicht, ein Moment.
Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie für das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch fertig sind, ja?
Okay.
Ich mache Sie ruhig ein paar Minuten, dass Sie Ihren Blut jetzt angucken.
Ich frage.
Oh ja, gerne.
Ja, Sie haben Blutschleimhautblutting mit Hüsten.
Bei Hüsten muss ich Blutigenschleimhaushüsten, ja?
Ja, wie oft fahre ich Sie?
Ich höre Sie, fuhlt bei Leise, ich muss ganz toll hinhören.
Wie oft?
Sag mir doch mal bitte Ihre Frage, ich kann das, also auf Hüsten nicht verstehen, das ist sehr leise.
Dr. Hatice, sagen Sie bitte noch einmal, das ist eine ganz, ich habe Ihre Stimme nicht verstanden, weil es so leise war.
Ja, wie oft haben Sie Blut mit Hüsten?
Oh, das habe ich eigentlich erst seit einigen Monaten und ja, vielleicht so 2 Mal am
Tag oder so?
2 Mal.
2 oder 3 Mal am Tag, ja, also in letzter Zeit auch, also schon, ja, auch etwas häufiger, ja?
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie geschwollene, gerötete oder überwarmte Beine bemerkt?
Geschwollene Lymphknochen, da weiß ich zu wenig davon, von, von, von, was sind Lymphknochen,
wo sitzen die, ich habe keine Schwellung bemerkt.
Ja, haben Sie geschwollene, gerötete, überwarmte Beine bemerkt?
Beine?
Ja, ja.
Die sind nicht besonders, würde ich sagen, es bin nicht aufgefallen, also die Socken schnüren
nicht ein.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie einen Schlafsturm, Gun?
Ja, also ich kann natürlich nicht gut schlafen, weil ich so früh beruhigt muss und dann,
wenn ich dann wacht wäre, muss ich natürlich auch auf die Toilette gehen und deswegen kann
ich also nicht so gut schlafen.
Gibt es bei Ihnen Brustchimmersin oder Engelgefühl?
Engelgefühl eigentlich nicht, aber beim Boosten tut es eigentlich ein bisschen weh, ja.
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Ja gerne.
Doktor Seine, können wir?
Ja, ich glaube.
Ja, gut.
Sagen herzte, Frau Oberarsten, ich möchte Ihnen heute unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Herr Simon ist 76 Jahre Patientin, da sich du wegen Tursis und Disziplinoe beibestellte
bei uns vorstellte?
Seit einem Monat.
Seit einem Monat?
Und der Patient berichtet das Fatigue und blutige Schupoten.
Ja.
Und die Frage nach Pyrrexium und Neuziaemesis wurde verneint.
Seit zehn Jahren arterialer Hypertonie.
Der Patient hat wegen Diskusprolapsus operiert worden.
Er ist operiert worden?
Er ist operiert worden.
Er ist.
Der Patient ist appendectomiert.
Und hat catarakt.
Reisanamnese ist unauffällig.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Augen tropfen, aber die Name und Dosierung unbekannt.
Er nimmt jeden Morgen und Abend.
Er nimmt 5 mg Konko.
Er nimmt einen Tablet gegen Prostate, die Perplasie.
Er nimmt aber die Dosierung und der Name unbekannt.
Er reagiert allergisch auf J.
Er regiert seit zehn Jahren.
Wir sind in der Diskussion.
Wir geben Ihnen Rückmeldungen.
An Vorerkrankungen gab er.
Er hat seit zehn Jahren einen hohen Blutdruck.
Er hat seit drei Monaten einen hohen Blutdruck.
Er ist voll wittwitt.
Er hat gesagt, das tut mir leid.
Aber dass die Eltern bei einem 80-Jährigen oder 75-Jährigen nicht mehr leben,
das ist ja eigentlich in der Natur der Sache.
Die müssten 100 sein ungefähr.
Kann ich sagen?
Das würde ich gar nichts dazu sagen.
Wenn die ganz früh gestorben sind oder wenn das ein Schicksal ist,
dann kann man vielleicht noch mal sagen, das tut mir leid.
Aber das tut mir leid.
Aber grundsätzlich, dass alte Leute an einer Krankheit sterben,
das liegt in der Natur der Sache.
Wir leben nun mal nicht unendlich.
Es gibt gute Ärzte, aber die können auch nicht alle Leben retten.
Das ist nun mal so.
Wenn mir heute jemand kontrollieren würde zum Tod meines Vaters,
der 25 Jahre zurück liegt, würde ich sagen, das passt nicht.
Das würde ich tatsächlich übergehen.
Da würde ich tatsächlich nur nachfragen,
vielleicht noch mal nach der Erkrankung.
Da haben Sie ja gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt.
Die Mutter hatte Brustkrebs und keinen Brunchalkart-Synom.
Hätte Sie einen Brunchalkart-Synom gehabt,
wäre das nochmal ein Indikator für unseren Patienten hier,
wenn das auch noch Familien an einem Nestisch wäre.
Gut, gut.
Ich habe Ihnen ziemlich viel Feedback gegeben.
Ich hoffe, das ist nützlich für Sie.
Ich hoffe, es ist nützlich auch für alle anderen, die mir zugehört haben.
Und versuchen Sie sich ein paar schöne Formulierungen,
vielleicht noch mal schriftlich vorzubereiten,
dass Sie nicht überrascht sind,
sondern dass Sie sich daran erinnern können,
das habe ich mal gut formuliert.
Dass Sie darauf zurückgreifen können.
Ich glaube, das wäre hilfreich.
Für mich ist da wichtig,
viele Informationen und Ihren Raten.
Vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Die Verständigung grundsätzlich fand ich eigentlich sehr gut.
Ich habe ja immer gewusst, was Sie wollen.
Nur wird in der Fachsprach-Krüfung
auch auf korrekte Grammatik wertgelegt.
Die Aussprache fand ich zum Beispiel ausgesprochen gut.
Ich konnte Sie sehr gut,
das, was Sie sagen, ist schon sehr gut verständlich.
Sie haben mich, glaube ich, auch immer gut verstanden.
Aber diese grammatikalischen Sachen,
das ist noch so eine Baustelle,
an der Sie ein bisschen arbeiten müssen.
Okay.
Okay, gut.